welcome congratulations on your new
position yes today is you've been right
Robin you're a courageous enough to sit
down here with me today and I know
everybody's very excited and interested
to hear what you have to say um you're
taking over the agency at a very
critical time for the country a very
critical time for corporate America as
we see of course and Snowden's
revelations and an increasing number of
cyber attacks happening to US companies
let me start just by asking you how do
you think business and the NSA can best
work together to try and solve some of
these cyber threats that exist right now
well first let me start off by saying
Chris thank you very much for taking
time Bloomberg government and all of you
who are taking the time from your busy
days for a discussion about what I think
is a very important topic for us as a
nation this whole idea of cyber security
I thank you very much for your
willingness to do that and engage in a
dialogue I apologize to you that I was a
couple minutes late unfortunately it
took like an hour and a half to drive
down from Fort Meade in the traffic
today and when I do it in the morning
every day because I live in the district
and drive up there we normally manage to
do it in 25 minutes so apologize to keep
you waiting
um well the first point I would make is
I am with you today really into a hat so
I wear both is the commander of United
States Cyber Command as well as the
director of the National Security Agency
in terms of my business colleagues that
the things I try to highlight are first
and foremost cyber security is something
that is foundational increasingly in the
world we are living in to your ability
to execute your business or your mission
whatever that is your failure to do so
successfully has the potential to
directly impact your ability to execute
your mission your corporations
reputation we're seeing that play out
over the last several months and some
very visible ways in the corporate
sector I try to tell business seniors
just as I try to tell military seniors
you must own this problem you cannot
simply say to your chief technical or
informational side hey this is your
problem go deal with it it's not
something that is worthy
my time it's not something that I really
need to focus on I have this same
dialogue with senior operational
commanders in the department where I try
to make the point this is just not your
IT and your computer people you have to
own this problem as a leader you have to
drive the change that inculcates this
into our culture we have to consider
this every bit as foundational as we do
our ability to maneuver forces end up
using a military construct as we care
about logistics as we care about our
infrastructure when I look at the
problem set I'm struck by a couple of
things that I also try to highlight with
my business counterparts traditionally
in my experience and you got to take
that for what it's worth traditionally
in my experience we've often largely
been focused on the attempts to prevent
intrusions I have increasingly come to
the opinion as I've done cyber for about
the last decade or so off and on within
the Department of Defense I am
increasingly coming to the opinion that
we must increasingly spend more time
focused on detection and so what do you
do when they get in because I wish that
we lived in a world where we can
guarantee no one's going to access or
gain entrance into our systems that is
becoming increasingly difficult so I
urge just as we have done within the
department you need to spend time asking
yourself what do I need to do to
maximize my detection capabilities so I
find out very early if someone's there
and then quite frankly what do I do
about it what do you do about it
do you go to the government about it do
you handle it on your own I think
there's a couple issues there clearly
there is a corporate fiduciary
responsibility to ensure the well-being
of your corporation and its ability to
execute its mission clearly I think when
you find something that's beyond the
scale of your ability as an entity to
deal with there's mechanisms for you to
reach out and say hey look this is an
area I need help from a governmental
perspective clearly there's Aires for
example of critical infrastructure where
as a nation we have a vested interest in
ensuring an author on uninterrupted
operations whether that might be in the
financial sector our power sector
fuel transportation air travel there's
clearly sectors here that are have
increased critical importance to our
ability as a nation to function
effectively which is one of the roles
for United States Cyber Command even as
US Cyber Command is tasked operated to
defend the networks within the
Department of Defense I have also been
tasked to be prepared when directed by
the President or the Secretary of
Defense to provide capability to support
civilian teammates in trying to deal
with many of these challenges
particularly those working in critical
infrastructure and to do that we have to
partner closely our primary partners in
this in the government being the
Department of Homeland Security and the
Federal Bureau of Investigation as well
as those key corporate entities who
potentially are receiving some of these
attacks or attempts to intrude in their
systems or deny their ability to operate
some of their public interfaces so if
I'm the CEO of a major technology
corporation and I see a significant
threat a threat that I think might be
coming from a foreign entity do I deal
with that on my own do I call the NSA do
I call Homeland Security what hi well
firstly the Department of Homeland
Security is primacy within the federal
government for dealing with the security
of networks outside the government now
what I would urge any corporation would
do I would urge you to reach out to the
Department of Homeland Security and
share what you are seeing at the moment
on the hill in fact right now up on the
in Congress we are they are debating is
there legislation that we could enact
that would in fact provide a means for
corporations to do that that's in a
process right now I am on record and my
confirmation hearing two-and-a-half
months ago I was asked and I said I
believe legislation is necessary that we
have tried to do this on a voluntary
basis over the last few years and while
that has generated increased cooperation
when I look at the number of incidents
that are voluntarily reported vais the
number of incidents that I believe are
truly happening out
boy there's a big Delta so I am a
proponent of legislation which would set
up a structure for the corporate world
to share information and for us on the
government side to share information
with our corporate teammates as we try
to deal with this because coming
together as a partnership is where we
can be very powerful as commander United
States Cyber Command is the director of
the National Security Agency I do not
have knowledge of private corporate
networks that's not where I spend my
time that's not where I'm focused that's
not my role my role I'm out in foreign
space trying to figure what is going on
in the cyber arena what's coming at us
as a nation what do we need to be
concerned about combats the NSA hat and
I say also brings great knowledge of in
our information assurance mission where
we are tasked within the government to
help develop capabilities to assess
networks their vulnerabilities help to
generate cryptographic standards for
example within the US government as well
as provide capability when directed to
support others in identifying malware
and other challenges associated with
defense of their networks and I say
brings an amazing technical capability
to this US Cyber Command brings a very
operational capability hey teams
organize equipped and trained to operate
in this space identify problems help in
the defensive side as well as
potentially work an offensive piece if
we're directed to do so you bring all
that together with our partners at the
FBI the Department of Homeland Security
and the capabilities that many corporate
entities have I spend some of my time in
this job getting to know corporate
counterparts and in many instances I am
incredibly impressed by the level of
effort I see by the capability of those
organizations have and by their
willingness to work with others I sure
would like to see us expand that to much
more a much broader segment of industry
in the corporate world the technology is
is
incredible and you just alluded to this
um so let me ask you about new reports
that show the NSA is using facial
recognition technology to monitor people
how does a program like that work well
I'm not going to get into specifics in
an open forum of what we do which I'll
be honest with you that is my greatest
challenge as the director of the
National Security Agency in order to
execute our mission of foreign
intelligence I have to be very very
mindful of my ability in large open
forums to talk about the specifics of
what we do now in my confirmation
hearing I was also very explicit about I
believe that as the director of NSA I
need to be more transparent well I can't
get into the specifics of the how we do
it I need to be willing to talk in broad
terms about what we do and why we do it
in a way that perhaps traditionally we
were not as comforting you tell me then
what the goal of a program like that
would be we use Fable facial recognition
as a tool to help us understand these
foreign intelligence targets we work
counterterrorism is another big area
this has probably had more impact for us
in the counterterrorism arena than
anywhere else where we see entities
through our signals intelligence
capabilities and we will know them
digitally if you will but we want to see
if we can try to understand them more
broadly to help our enable our broader
efforts to bring them to justice and to
forestall their ability to conduct
attacks against ourselves and our allies
and friends and the world around us we
do not if I could just finish one thing
Trish we do not do this in some
unilateral basis against US citizens
I do not access stay at one point I saw
someone say well they must be accessing
Department of Motor Vehicle I mean you
don't have to stay on me you don't I'm
like no we don't do that we have very
specific restrictions when it comes to
us persons we have to operate under a
legal framework but you don't have
access to driver's license you don't
have acts
to passport photos um you would think a
candidate would have access to some of
those things I mean we're talking about
for us persons come do this for us
persons again why our mission is as the
NSA is very explicit its foreign
intelligence and information assurance
foreign intelligence connected we have
to do anything involving a u.s. person
we have specific legal constraints we
must comply with
we just don't unilaterally decide hey
today I'm going to go after citizen X Y
or Z we don't do that we can't legally
do that but there are people that you
know you want to be in to target in the
dip that there are let me finish one
thought before I forget and we'll get
back that clearly in the digital age we
will encounter American persons in the
wilderness out there so to speak and we
have specific restrictions about what
happens once we do encounter US persons
in broad terms we've got to stop what
we're doing if we come to the
realization that somebody that we're
monitoring that we're tracking is a u.s.
connection that we were unaware of in
broad terms we have to stop what we're
doing we have to assess the situation
that if we think there's a legal basis
to this then we have to get a legal
authority or justification to continue
it was interesting to me in you know
we've all heard this interchange with
our gentlemen in Moscow over the last
few days the part that I thought was
interesting was as he was talking about
you know hey I reached out to NSA and
told them I had concerns and we came
back and said hey I haven't seen that I
haven't been able to find that hey the
one thing we've been able to find the
one thing we've been able to find
referenced his annual training you know
what that annual training was about that
we make every employee go through
safeguarding of us persons information
that was the training that he was going
through the course that he had completed
that all of us have to that course
generated a question in his mind it from
my perspective that's a good thing I
tell the workforce you need to
ask if there are things you are
uncertain about that's why we have
feedback that's why we have those
collaboration mechanisms it's important
that each of us you know meet our
expectations and our requirements and
our duties that's the only way this will
work so then let's equip someone who's
known for I mean it we'll take the
Bergdahl case for example as it relates
to intelligence gathering we're now
sending five members of the Taliban back
to Qatar can the NSA track them there
Bergdahl is not something I'm gonna get
into but no no I I'm not asking this
early to times you can tell I just gave
a very direct person no that's nice
that's good we appreciate the directness
and and and I just wonder can the NSA at
least I mean these are foreigners
they're known threats can we track them
overseas so we have the means to track
individuals with a foreign intelligence
dimension to them yes am I going to sit
here and guarantee every we can track
every individual constantly no you're
not going to hear me talk about that
again oftentimes part of the dialogue
I've heard I think wow I wish we had the
breakfast capability that at times I
hear I mean does NSA control the end I'm
like what you really believe that that
is just not the case and then like I
said we operate under the rule of law
and as the new director I've been in
place 60 days as you heard in the
introduction when I tell the workforces
we have an important mission it matters
to the nation it matters to our allies
and our friends what also matters is
that we do it right and we do it
correctly the nation has entrusted us
with a great responsibility we are not
going to let them down by abusing that
trust or abusing those resources now a
broad dialogue about what we're doing
and why is a good thing for us as a
nation I don't question that for one
minute because as much as I am proud of
being a flag office of the United States
Navy I am also mindful I was a citizen
in this nation before I ever started
this journey in uniform and when this
journey is
I just want to go back to being just
another citizen again and I have no
intention of compromising myself for
what I believe it in the execution of my
duties we're just not going to do that
there's nothing worth that in my
experience you mentioned Ed Snowden what
harm has he done to the country and to
your agency today no again I have been
on record when when asked I am watching
foreign nations groups individuals cite
his disclosures and saying we need to
change the way we operate the Americans
have insight here we need to do
something differently so you think that
potential threats are operating
differently because of I am watching
those foreign intelligence and
counterterrorism targets some of them
not going to make a blanket statement
again everybody's changing everything
but I'm watching them highlight the
revelations talk about their
implications to them and what they do
and how they communicate that is
unsettling to me as an individual Turk
charged with generate knowledge and
insight that helps this nation
understand the world around it and
increases our ability to forestall
attempts on the part of others to do
harm to us our interests and our allies
that makes the job harder sir any idea
how many documents he took um we have a
fairly good idea again I'm not going to
get into specifics all this because I'd
be the first event one of the things
that I try to tell the work force out
there is this is not what is going to
define us we cannot go into this punch
down crunch we have an important mission
we've got to keep doing the mission and
we got to do it right that's what
matters to me we'll have a broader
dialogue as a nation and that's a good
thing then we'll play one part in that
dialogue that will involve many many
people and many many perspectives and
that's exactly the way it should be but
for us as an organization I need you
focused on the mission and doing things
right you know let me take the heat on
the outside that's what they pay me for
because imagine if you're in this
workforce
every review from the outside world to
date has come to the conclusion there
has been no systematic violation of law
or policy on the part of the National
Security Agency it is executing a series
of laws and policies that have been put
in place in accordance with this
governmental structure that we call
America now we can have a debate about
is that policy the best one are those
laws where we want to be I think that's
a very fair debate but for the men and
women of the National Security Agency I
think the greater majority of them find
themselves at times very confused and
perplexed Hey
the outside world has looked at us it
has assessed us it has come to the
conclusion that we have not knowingly in
a broad scale attempted to circumvent
law or violate procedure and yet I go
home and my family asks you ask me hey
what are you doing with my phone Hey
I go to the grocery store I got candy I
mean you can play how are your kids
right I go to I go to church i watch a
workforce trying to deal with the fact
hey look we're doing what we think isn't
something that's important we're doing
something we think that matters and
increases the safety of our citizens
we're doing in a way that complies with
law and policy Wow why is it that you
know all my friends and neighbors are
looking at me so differently now we used
to you know call ourselves the silent
service if you go into the National
Security Agency you will find a black
wall in which 173 names are carved a
week ago yesterday we added two new
names to that wall that wall is a
hundred and seventy three people who
have given their lives as a part of the
NSA team and the defense of the nation
one week ago today we added chief petty
officer Kristian Pike and Air Force
Staff Sergeant Richard Dixon who died in
Afghanistan and on that wall we say they
served in silence that is the culture
they can argue if it's a good or bad
culture but it is the culture of the
organization hey we
do things that matter but we do them in
a way that doesn't compromise what we do
or bring attention to ourselves it's not
about us it's about the mission well one
person did not adhere to that culture
did you watch ed Snowden's interview no
to be honest tight you didn't tell us I
was traveling it at the time it came on
I've seen clips of it something I've
seen some clips I'm so so what was your
impression of him in those clips
did he seem prepped did he seem coached
what's your thought I don't know that's
not my place I thought again I think he
had to be very balanced I thought he's
an intelligent individual articulate um
he seemed fairly arrogant to me um he
believes clearly believes in what he's
doing I don't question that I don't
agree with it I fundamentally disagree
with what he did I believe it was wrong
I believe it was illegal from my
perspective
he stole sensitive information that he
had been entrusted with he abused the
trust of his workplace colleagues in
doing so um do you really believe he he
fundamentally believes in what he did or
do you think he could have been working
for someone else as a double agent
could he have and possibly do I believe
that that's the case probably not but I
really I would I would caution everyone
look we've got a set of processes that
will deal with this issue in the long
run and that's the way we need to go as
citizens we are free to express our
opinions that's a real strength for us
as a nation the challenge in my mind is
we cannot function as a society if every
one of us unilaterally decides I'm right
everyone else is wrong and I am going to
disregard the law and decide what I'm
going to agree to adhere to or not
adhere to I spoke with your predecessor
Keith Alexander just yesterday on the
phone and he expressed the concern that
he thought and Snowden was at some point
it's a question of when working for
someone else possibly the Russians he
might be working for them right now I
mean do you think that's a theory that's
important to explore it's funny he can
clearly we're gonna be and run at all
the ground you know my comment would be
be part of the dialogue if you believe
in this use the power of the law and the
structures of our society to make your
case the answer is not for any one of us
to unilaterally decide that I'm the
all-knowing Oracle who knows everything
that I'm in the best position to decide
what is right or wrong be leery of a
society in which everyone unilaterally
can do that we love to quote the
Constitution that document provides a
framework for us as to how we're going
to organize as a government as well as
how we're going to settle disputes
through this framework we call the law
and I urge all of us as citizens you use
that framework if there's something that
you feel strongly about make your case
make an argument articulate your
viewpoint but do it within the framework
that we all have to use if we're going
to exist as a society if we're going to
function as a nation beware of the chaos
associated with all of us unilaterally
deciding what we want to do what we
don't want to do what laws we're going
to obey what laws we're going to choose
to disobey that just comes across to me
as incredibly arrogant yes again that's
just my opinion you know you talk so
much about the culture of the NSA I mean
there's certainly a you know a culture
in our military um how is it that a guy
like Ed Snowden gets essentially kicked
out of the CIA there's a derogatory
report written about him concerns that
he was trying to break into systems at
the CIA and then he winds up working for
the NSA
I mean in terms of background checks
what's done what needs to change so you
don't have another Edward Snowden I mean
clearly we need to look at it the flip
side though is um I don't want to go too
far in the other direction what do I
mean by that I mean I already have
members of the work force saying now let
me understand this
I haven't done anything wrong and yet
you're taking increased security
measures hey why am i paying the price
for this you're doing this right now I
anything why should I be questioned
because of the actions of one
vigil so it's always about trying to
find that that balance now at some point
I hope in our time we're actually to
talk about cybersecurity we will we will
of course we will we are but I believe
one might have a lady
um but you gotta love that great part
about Emma Rodgers it always is very dry
it's just curious that it seems as the
one agency is not necessarily talking to
the other because couldn't you have
learned this is a guy who's got
something on his record I mean don't get
me wrong
clearly we wish we had known that but on
the other hand again he was a contract
it wasn't an employee of ours now he had
access to our system so get me wrong you
granted him access are you on a percent
confident that you have no edward
snowden's in your ranks right now would
I ever I would never tell you I mean my
question be what idiot would say
something like that so what have you
change there are a few there are a few
certainties in the world mm so how about
that cyber security base could we really
get we will talk about I got I got one
more question for you know just on Ed
Snowden and we'll move on in terms of
amnesty um would you consider it an
excuse for him turning back all the
documents that he took that's not my
decision but in the digital age we're
living in the idea of controlling once
it's out there I think is very
problematic do you think it's out there
do you think basically it may have meant
it surely doesn't have the doesn't have
the controlled I wish it had could could
it be in the hands of the Russians or
the Chinese or any other there could
well be aspects of that um I promise we
will talk about cyber through silicon so
this is you know ed Snowden the target
attack
you know eBay the other day coming out
telling the world they needed to change
their passwords we're living in an
environment where cybersecurity is front
and center on everyone's mind and yet
it's not right because we take a lot of
things for granted is there
an equivalent of a cyber 911 I mean do
we need to be incredibly vigilant when
it comes to these attacks what really
worries unicycle I mean I clearly hope
we don't need a 911 to remember 911
almost 3,000 us and other citizens of
other nations died in one day
I don't think any of us ever want to see
something like that again and I
certainly hope it doesn't take a
traumatic event and I'm not trying to
argue it's got to be loss of life but if
you look at impact if you look at cost I
sure hope we don't have to get to that
kind of level to urge us to step back to
say wow perhaps we need to do things a
little differently what I'm hoping is
clearly all of us see what is happening
in the world around us the level of
sophistication the volume and the focus
of this effort is increasing across our
entire society we experience it as
private citizens I think I've read
something that something like 27% of
Americans now within the last two years
have experienced the personal data
compromised if you look at the numbers
for us as individuals if you look at
what we're seeing in the corporate world
if you look at what we're seeing in the
US government then particularly you know
in the hat I wear is US Cyber Command
what we're seeing directed against the
Department of Defense the level of
effort the complexity just continues to
grow doing what we have always done I
would argue is not really going to get
us where we need to be in this world
that we can see unfolding in front of us
so we can either recognize this and
drive ourselves to change or we can just
sit back it reminds me a little about as
a Navy guy you always used to joke when
you're swimming in the ocean you just
got to make sure you're faster than the
guy next to you when it comes to that
shark so and then there that's not
employment that's not the attitude that
I hope we have I see some because for
some you know it's a very business case
analysis you know what's the risk versus
what's the cost and I think for some the
assessment has been perhaps I'm not
large perhaps I'm not in the core market
segment for
so I have enough capability I can afford
to continue what I'm doing I can deal
with the risk
I'll mitigate it if we have to but I
don't want to put the time the energy
the resources the money upfront if you
will and don't get me wrong every entity
has to decide what's right for them I
understand I'm not going to sit here and
argue hey this is the right level of
investment we have tried to work within
the government on developing standards
if you will
partnering with NIST and others that we
have tried to promulgate across the
federal government as well as the civil
sector to say look these are standards
that we believe we would urge you to
adopt they think that if you do if you
do that it significantly increases your
ability to forestall penetrations it
significant increases your ability to
deal with penetrations should they occur
so we're putting collectively a lot of
work into it but we clearly are not
where we need today you asked so what
are sophisticated right I mean and think
about what you have in front of you
you've got to stay in front of all these
people around the world that are trying
more more sophisticated means to break
into systems how do you recruit the very
best talent to help you do that I mean
you're competing with you know the likes
of Google you are competing for these
mathematicians these engineers and they
have the opportunity to go to Silicon
Valley and get stock options right so
why do they come to work for you I think
it's the same reason the argument I've
made with our leadership is look we are
never talking about NSA and even in the
military you as cyber communities we're
trying to attract those same kinds of
people we are never going to get Pete on
the basis of money if that's the metric
we're just not going to be the place
they go where can we compete hey we're
about serving something bigger than
ourselves we're about an ethos of right
and wrong we're about doing a mission
that's important to the nation we're
about doing some things that quite
frankly you can't do legally on the
outside that will really challenge you
that will test you that will give you
the opportunity to use cutting-edge
technology and apply it in a way that
will help with the defense of the nation
that Jazz's most
and the positive side for us is I'm not
running into problems either under US
Cyber can or is the director the
National Security Agency in terms of
attracting quality people who want to be
part of the team and don't get me wrong
it's something I pay lots of attention
to because I am very mindful we have a
lot of technology but if you ask me what
do I where do I think the true value
resides it's the people that's where we
get the true value and it's not just
their gray matter it's here it's their
heart and their dedication and their
willingness to work some incredibly long
hours if that's what it takes this is a
culture about mission and doing the
right thing and doing it for the right
reasons I am proud to be the director of
NSA I am proud to be the commander of US
Cyber Command I tell the workforce
I believe in NSA I believe in Cyber
Command I didn't have to take this job I
did it for a reason
because I believe in the mission of the
team I believe in the men and women who
executed and I thought is it
particularly as I was joined the NSA
team hey we're in a tough spot right now
I could walk away and just say hey not
my problem I don't need the heartache
but I said to myself what kind of leader
Rogers would you be if you did that you
spent your whole adult life working in
this field of sigit and cyber now it's
payback time you own and so that's why I
stand before you sit before yeah now
well we appreciate it we appreciate the
transparency let me ask you I you know I
talked to a lot of tech CEOs on
Bloomberg TV and I've heard a lot of
frustration from the tech community
regarding all these revelations and the
spying that has come to light and the
concern is that we are getting ourselves
into a somewhat protectionist
environment Cisco for instance right now
is it risk of losing its China contracts
over cyber spying so what do you say to
CEOs like John Chambers to make them
feel as though you know we are still
moving forward as a globe
economy despite these concerns about one
nation spying on another and the other
nation spying back Jack um well first I
certainly appreciate the concern and I
don't push back argument well boy what
what who are you to think that far from
it hey he like many others have a
responsibility to their organization I
understand that and I'll question the
concern at all as we work our way
through this that the points I try to
make to my corporate counterparts are
look what we're doing is the activity
that almost every significant
nation-state on this planet does it
attempts to gain insights on the world
around it attempts to forestall threats
to its citizens I don't care if it's
China I don't care if it's Russia I
don't care for it so let's fill in the
blank every nation tries to do that for
the well-being of its citizens
now varying nations have varying degrees
of capability we clearly have amazing
capability within the construct of the
US government to help generate insight
and knowledge of the world around us and
to help defend our citizens you have
seen some of that play out what hasn't
played out in many ways to be is so I
appreciate the technology now talk to me
about what are the constraints that are
in place to assure that this isn't miss
abuse we haven't at any discussion about
that talk to me about the laws that are
in place to forestall your ability to
use this and legally against our
citizens talk to me about the
protections you have put in place to
make sure your work force can't abuse
this Authority talk to me about why do
you feel you need to do this what's the
why is it in our best interest that's
the kind of discussion
why is our best interested it's a
national national security right my
attic tonight comment would be because
it's a matter of our security as a
nation and one of the challenges of
being one of the largest most powerful
nations in the world is there are a lot
of people out there don't have our best
interest at heart
there are groups and individuals out
there who if they had their way we would
no longer exist as a nation now I'm not
one who's going to sit here and overhype
the threat that in the name of this
threat we have to make dramatic changes
and curtail our rights because if we go
down that road in the end they've won if
we change who we are and what we believe
and what we represent in the name of
security they have won I have always
believed that and I can remember as a no
six having a conversation with I worked
for a chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff at the time and said hey sir you
know I think this is an important role
for you as a chairman as the principal
military adviser to the US government
you know we do not want to destroy
ourselves or become something we aren't
in the name of security that's not a
good thing for us but in the trying to
achieve that level of security we do
have to acknowledge that that threat
exists it's not something we're making
up we have lost and our allies have lost
literally thousands of citizens in the
last decade from individuals who have
and continue to attempt to generate
threats to take down our citizens to
distribute it to in a very if they had
their way and sometimes very spectacular
ways we've been very successful in for
stalling much of it much of the things
we have for stalled as citizens you will
never ever know about and you will never
ever hear about that is the nature of
intelligence it is the nature of our
business but if the Chinese don't trust
American tech companies and American
tech companies don't trust Chinese
companies are we on the verge of seeing
some kind of protectionist trade war as
a result of sign is it possible yes in
the long run is it likely I don't think
so but I could I could well be wrong
them certainly in the long run why not
and so because I believe in the end
competition and the quality of what we
do and the value of what our
corporations offer moving out in the end
it's not by chance that the US enjoys
such a significant advantage in this
market sector it's because of what we're
able to produce I believe in the end the
value of what we produce will stand for
itself
the DOJ indicted five Chinese officers
on accusations of cyber espionage
recently did the NSA planning rollin yes
but I won't get into the specifics in
what we did um does it seem like a tit
for tat scenario I mean that's that's
what the business community is worried
about no I mean it was again what is the
framework we use to resolve issues like
this a legal framework not just one
nation talking about what you're doing
this and another nation talking about
what you're doing that hey that's why we
have courts that's why we have the rule
of law and ultimately if it proceeds to
a trial a judge and a jury will make a
decision that's the way our system works
what with that I apologize well just one
final question we have 40 seconds and I
think this would be a good way to wrap
up Admiral um what can you tell American
citizens right here today that are
worried that they will never be fully
anonymous or have a right to full
privacy again in the digital age of the
21st century we as a society have to
come to grips with what does privacy
mean in the world we're living in today
that's a much bigger question than
what's the role the National Security
Agency because in the world we're living
in increasingly by choice and by chance
we are forfeiting privacy at levels that
I don't think as individuals we truly
understand and it is so engrained
whether it's the cameras that are out on
the street whether it's every one of
your personal digital devices that are
constantly asking you can I share where
you are whether it's you know the
questions that we get asked in trying to
do business hey give me your social
security number hey give me your zip
code hey tell me how often you shop with
me we're in the world of big data like
it or like it or not we are in the
digital age in the world of big data and
we increasingly as a nation and it's not
just us we've got to come to grips with
what does that mean and what are we
comfortable with we have framed this
debate way too narrow from my
perspective this isn't much bigger than
the National Security Agency
this is a much broader dialogue I think
we need to have and that's what John
Podesta has been doing with the White
House and you saw the president's
remarks on the 17th of January where he
said hey look we need to think about
this more broadly that's an important
question for us as a nation
what are we comfortable with but on the
first movement the idea that you can be
totally anonymous in the digital age is
increasingly difficult to execute that's
just hard thank you Dad well thank you
very much thank you